jours avec les amoureux du grand raid il
est 9 heures du matin on est un peu plus
de douze heures maintenant du départ du
grand raid
nous sommes à la bretagne chez nikko et
alexandra kla ils sont en train de se
préparer on va les rejoindre
remplacé par 98 voix bien 98 toi ici 85
donc là ce n'est pas on est rendu à 30
on a fait notre petite feuille de route
donc on n'essaie pas de mettre les temps
pour voir quand on pas si on est dans la
fourchette haute voix la couverture de
survie
la pile comme d'habitude umich et le
côté parce que sincèrement utilisé la
nuit donc c'est là dans une petite poche
avec 120 c'est quoi le secret bancaire
et d'un bon ça que c'est bien ranger
nettoyer pour que ça gêne pas ça et ça
balance pas refaire et on sait quand on
mémorise c'est pour ça je me répète
quand je mets jeudi mal an que de
rechange eux mais dès hier quand je me
répète en fin de compte ça reste dans la
mémoire voilà et après ça mais ça je
suis revenu au sein
donc on a toutes deux dans là j'ai mes
réserves alimentaires ça c'est du
magnésium actif que je prends je mets là
là je suis à cinq cents 500 250 ça fait
1 kg 250 plus d y est je pense que je
vous dois avoir à les trois kilos trois
culots ccc après mon nico et alexandra
figure parmi les meilleurs raider pays
elle a terminé première réunionnaise en
2015 et 2016 lui était premier
réunionnais en 2012 mais un problème au
coeur là depuis empêchés de participer
aux grands rêves
du coup c'était dit sur 2017 est
doublement une affaire de coeur oui
c'est ça le mot de le dire si on prenne
compte déjà j'ai eu un problème de coeur
une cardiopathie ma fille n'arrive à 1 a
réussi que maintenant la raison il
emporte un petit peu sur le voilà sur
l'excitation de faire la compétition
tout ça donc là prit une autre une autre
manière de voir la compétition donc que
maintenant mais en fin de compte le fait
de me peut courir avec alexandra c'est
que du bonheur je mets des carottes mais
nissan ac c'est juste pour une soupe on
fait une soupe au rheu campardon en
altitude des carottes et des pommes de
terre tout est prêt mikko et alexandra
vont maintenant essayer de dormir un peu
il est maintenant 17 heures le départ du
grand raid c'est dans moins de six
heures maintenant ça y est il est temps
d'y aller mikko alexandra oui bah oui il
est là en ce moment on attend tout cas
de démarrer vous avez réussi à dormir un
peu petit peu plus se reposer
tiens pas quoi donc au bout du fil un
des deux fils klein prend des nouvelles
depuis toulouse se reprendre en 10
minutes et baadiko bah on n'aura pas
beaucoup de temps pour parler alors ces
chantiers de nous appeler
on respirera profiter de ses derniers
instants parce que quand on va prendre
oui après ça va te faudra tenir le plus
dur ça va tenir la nuit ne pas dormir et
2e i sa deuxième nuit voilà donc on sait
qu'ils ce qui nous attend on sait la
difficulté
donc voilà et après on sait qu'on va ça
va pas être facile même si on est bien
préparé on dit qu'on a tout prévu et
après on sait se prépare à vivre les
moments des moments difficiles quand
écoute moi bien
et sinon et dans les moments difficiles
on a pensé aux petits messages
voilà le petit garçon à la fille qui
restent à la maison à nos gars à son ca
c est pour autant
la nuit est tombée nous retrouvons nos
deux amoureux sur un parking de saint
pierre
dernier message à la famille le temps
est à la concentration avant d'affronter
la foule
il est bientôt 21h dans un peu plus
d'une heure le départ ça va la tension
monte un peu bombe amicaux et alexandra
n'ont même plus le temps de répondre les
amis coureurs les entourent déjà mais
également leurs clients car dans la vie
mikko alexandra classe sur vase a
ratissé de course à une ambiance veut
partir c'est une ambiance tout à fait
particulier avant m oui mais là on voit
déjà on est déjà dans la ferveur
on a même des clients du marché ils nous
encouragent
c'est là qu'on comprend trop violent
[Musique]
réserves d'eau 2
réserves alimentaires
il ya du miel là et sur la zone de
départ
c'est maintenant une véritable haie
d'honneur qui attend mikko et alexandra
joyeuse à bien certains mariages mais
assez merci parce que vous êtes un
exemple justement parce que comme ça que
free
si cette joie parce que là c'est
possible vingt-cinq porte mariage le
couple salue la foule des raideurs et
rejoint à présent l'espace réservé aux
favoris du grand raid
nous on va se poser aussi parce
qu'autrement c'est alors que mikko et
alexandra retrouve marcelle puy dans un
petit coin la grand'mare celle qui elle
aussi salut les amoureux du grand raid
on en est là à nous allécher venus
depuis ce matin et quand freddy thévenin
vient rejoindre la petite bande les
meilleurs réunionnais ne peuvent pas
résister au plaisir d'un septennat
il ne reste plus qu'à métro quoi la
stratégie de course alexandra partira
devant et mikko ensuite la rejoindra
peut partir vraiment tranquille et après
ces dates si je rattrape alexandre a
essayé de rester avec elle et après
finir lesquels ça serait on finit à dos
les deux ça serait magnifique
la fille exactement
hormis on
midest obama s'est aussi dit
kg messieurs la série
merci
[Musique]
on